من احتجاز النشطاء الى الصحفيات
استراتيجيه يتبعها النظام الايراني لقمع
منعلت اصواتهم داخليا ضد ممارسته بشكل
منهجي بحسب منظمه مراسلون بلا حدود تحاول
ايران جاهده اسكت النساء من خلال توقيف
عدد غير مسبوقا من الصحفيات في حملتها ضد
الاحتجاجات على مقتل مهسه امينه
المنظمه اوضحت ايضا ان حوالي نصف الصحفيين
الذين قبض عليهم اخيرا هم من النساء من
بينهن اثنتان تواجهان عقوبه الاعدام اذا
وجهت السلطات الايرانيه الاتهام الى
الوفير حامدي والى هي محمدي وهما صحفيتانا
كانتا من اول من لفت الانتباه الى وفاه
امينه بتهمه الدعايه ضد النظام والتامل ضد
الامن القوميه وهما تهمتان قد تؤديان الى
عقوبه الاعدام
[موسيقى]
افعال تكشف الستاره عن نوايا النظام
الايراني في قمع الاحتجاجات التي تهدد
قبضتها على السلطه فيما تعلو مطالبات
عديده بضروره اطلاق سراح الصحفييتين دون
قيد او شرط
احتجاجات تخطت جراتها ما تعتبرها السلطات
الايرانيه خطوط حمرا 42 صحفيا على الاقل
في كل انحاء ايران اوقفوا منذ انطلاق
الاحتجاجات افرج عن ثمانيه منهم ولا
تزالوا 15 صحفيه من بين 34 صحفيا
رهن الاحتجاز
[تصفيق]